>> Male Speaker: Hi everyone, and welcome
to another Authors at Google event up in the
San Francisco office.
Today we’re very pleased to welcome Stephanie
Palmer to Google.
Stephanie’s a former Hollywood executive,
former denizen of Los Angeles as well, who
is now, um, gone to just as sunny climates
in Santa Fe, where it may be slightly calmer.
Um, she used to be a Hollywood executive with
MGM, and now she’s a, uh, pitching and presentation
consultant and she wrote a book called “Good
in a Room,” which she will reference today.
Um, which is how to sell yourself and your
ideas, and win over any audience.
She’s been featured on the Today Show on
NBC, the Early Show on CBS, The Los Angeles
Times, National Public Radio and the Atlantic
and Incorporated magazines.
Please welcome Stephanie Palmer to Google.
[Clapping]
>> Stephanie Palmer: Have you ever had, what
you thought, was a big idea?
Only when you shared it with someone else,
they didn’t really get it.
Or have you made a presentation in a meeting
that fell flat?
Or you have a really great idea and you share
that with your supervisor, only to have them
not pursue it?
So, let’s be honest, sometimes ideas are
not that good.
But sometimes, you have a really great idea,
but it doesn’t get the financing or the
attention that it deserves.
>>Stephanie Palmer: So why does this happen?
This happens for the same reason that Hollywood
makes so many bad movies.
Well, of course, there are plenty of reasons
why Hollywood makes lots of bad movies, but
one of the main reasons happens early in the
process when they’re deciding which projects
they want to purchase.
So, Hollywood producers and executives hear
hundreds of pitches before they decide which
select few are going to be those best bets.
And those best bets often aren’t the best
ideas, but they are likely to be the best
pitches.
>>Stephanie Palmer: So, here’s the thing,
when ideas are initially competing for investment,
mediocre ideas pitched well beat out great
ideas pitched poorly.
Let me say that again, mediocre ideas pitched
well often beat out great ideas pitched poorly.
And this is why I want to help people learn
how to pitch, because I want to level the
playing field so that the great ideas can
stand out.
>> Stephanie Palmer: Uh, the, the main point
of today’s whole thing, is that basically
I, I believe that when the best ideas win,
we all benefit.
>>Stephanie Palmer: Let me tell you a little
bit about my background.
I started in Hollywood as an intern on the
movie “Titanic.”
And then I moved to Jerry Bruckheimer films,
where I worked on “Armageddon” and “Enemy
of the State.”
And Jerry would be very happy that I saw one
of your conference rooms here is for “The
Rock.”
[laughing]
He would be very happy, um, about that.
Then I moved to MGM, where I was the director
of creative affairs.
And my job was, basically, to help supervise
the development and production of films.
And, part of my job was hearing pitches from
writers and directors.
And over six years, I had more than 3,000
pitch meetings.
And it was in those meetings, that I really
paid attention to what was working and what
didn’t, and I discovered that the best part
of my job, was working on pitches.
So, I decided to start my own company, focused
solely on pitching.
Now, um, part of my business plan, as I was
starting my business, was to write a book.
And I was building my client base, and I had
put together a book proposal, and I had sent
it to New York and got some interest of publishers.
So, they invited me to come to New York, and
I was like, “Great!”
Ok, so I get to New York and I’m sitting
in the lobby for my first meeting at this
big publishing house and suddenly I started
to get a little nervous.
And I went into the meeting and I was sitting
there on this nice leather couch, in this
lovely office in Manhattan, and the editor,
who I was expecting to come in with like a
big friendly face and, ya know, a nice handshake,
came in and said, right to my face, “I hate
Hollywood and everything that it stands for.”
And I was a little taken aback, and I, uh,
was like, “Oh, oh okay.”
Um, and so then I started talking to him and
he basically grilled me for the entire meeting.
We never got to my part of the pitch.
Um, he basically was telling me that I represented
everything that he hated about tabloid celebrity
culture and frankly, I was totally unprepared
for that.
I had thought going into the meeting, “Oh,
he’s bought books that are similar to mine,
he’s, I’m prepared for the meeting, I
can, ya know, have a fine meeting.
Um, but basically, I was stumbling and rambling
and it didn’t seem like I knew at all what
I was talking about.
The irony was not lost on me that the book
I was pitching was called, “Good in a Room“,
and I was not.
So totally humbled, I had a few hours to regroup
before my next meeting.
So I went back and I wrote down all the questions
that he had asked me and I developed better
answers.
I practiced out loud in the hotel room, ya
know, mirror, um, and I got myself ready for
the mental stress of having to be on the spot.
And my subsequent meetings went quite a bit
better.
They were far from perfect, but each time
I got better.
And, by the end of the week, there were five
publishers that made offers, and I sold my
book to Random House.
So, uh, to tell you about my current clients,
as you would expect, most of the people that
I work with are still pitching TV and film
projects, but I also, over the last five years,
have branched out.
And, so, I have worked with executives at,
Merrill Lynch, Accenture, Mattel, Los Alamos
National Laboratories, and also a wide variety
of entrepreneurs.
One of the entrepreneurs that I worked with
very recently is, uh, has invented a new kind
of airplane.
And, now why I share this, is because I am
not an engineer, I am not an aviation expert,
but the ideas in his pitch are solely his
own, but what I did is help take his ideas
and make it so that other people could understand
them and also see their value.
And currently he has secured his first round
of financing and is developing a 65 pound
prototype.
Now, it’s true that different fields have
different criteria for evaluating ideas.
But, there are some things that are, um, similar
across a wide varieties of situations.
So, before we get started, here’s a fun
fact.
My brother Tim, works here as a strategic
partner and development manager, so, “Hello
Tim.”
[laughter]
Um, and I know that this is an elite group.
You guys have strong soft skills, because
you have made it through the rigorous and
infamous Google interviewing process.
I also know that there’s a wide variety
of jobs.
There’s engineers, there’s people who
work in ad sales, there’s marketing.
Ya know, you have, you encounter a bunch of
different pitching scenarios.
Um, but I think that there are some things
that hold true through a wide variety of settings.
So, if you’re in a more formal pitch, something
like, you are pitching to a major advertiser
or partner, that’s what I consider a more
formal pitch, or you’re presenting your
ideas in the product review meeting or global
product strategy meeting.
Or there’s plenty of more casual situations,
like, you’re building consensus in a room
of your peers.
Or you’re talking to your ,uh, supervisor
about your 20% project.
Uh, all of these pitches basically are unique,
that’s something to know is that, there’s
not a one size fits all for how to pitch.
But, I’m really interested in that those
specific situations, so those little things
like, what, um, exactly what you say and how
to say it in a specific situation.
It’s that fine tuning that I really like,
because it’s often those small changes that
you make, that make the big difference.
So, let’s talk about, um , the wide variety
of pitching situations.
You have the formal situations and you have
the more casual.
And there are five techniques that I’m gonna
cover today, that apply in that wide variety.
And those are, start by stepping back, write
your pitch to be spoken, let the audience
be the judge, sell yourself as well as your
idea and embrace pitching early in the development
process.
So let’s start at the beginning.
Let’s define three terms.
First, pitch.
People talk about pitch or pitching and mean
lots of different things.
I define pitching as verbally transferring
information in order to get someone to act.
Second, decision maker.
The decision maker is the person who’s listening
to that pitch.
And the decision is whether or not they’re
going to support your idea in some way.
The third term is good in a room.
Someone who pitches well to decision makers
is good in a room.
Someone, uh, this term originated in Hollywood,
I didn’t come up with it.
Um, agents use it, coined it, to describe
actors who are their, their most successful
and their most charismatic, those people are
referred to as being good in a room.
And, uh, someone who’s known for being good
in a room is the actor Kevin Spacey.
And I worked with Kevin on the movie 21.Which,
as you may know, was that film about the six
MIT students who card counted at black jack
and won millions in Las Vegas.
So, I was working with Kevin and talking about
how he first got his start.
And, what he did at the beginning, before
he became a famous actor, is he would partner
with writers, who were good writers but felt
really uncomfortable pitching.
And so Kevin would go to the meeting with
the writers, he would pitch the story and
sell it and then he would take a cut of the
profits.
So eventually, the writers who he was partnered
with learned to successfully pitch on their
own.
And the point of this is that, though there
are some people who are born with a natural
charisma, anybody, even shy, introverted people,
can learn to become good in a room.
So, let’s start at the beginning.
The first, um, technique is basically, a key
question when you’re developing a pitch
is, where do you start?
And in my experience, uh, a lot of pitches,
most people start too far in and that’s
why they don’t get off to a good start.
So we’re gonna start by stepping back, is
my first technique.
Here’s an example of what I mean.
Last week I heard a movie pitch from a writer,
and he was saying to me, ya know, “Stephanie,
my project is a pitch about a spy,” and
he’s going along, he’s describing the
set pieces, he’s talking about, ya know,
what’s gonna happen in the plot at each
point.
He’s going along, and it’s just not really
adding up for me.
So, he’s going along and then he says, “Stephanie,
why aren’t you laughing?”
[laughing]
Well, he was intending for the spy to be someone
like Austin Powers from The Spy Who Shagged
Me, but the whole time I was listening, I
assumed he meant a serious operative like
Jason Bourne, from The Bourne Identity.
So this could have been easily solved if he
had just started with, “my project is a
comedy, about, da, da, da, a spy who does
this.”
So I see the same kind of thing with the entrepreneurs
that I work with.
They start talking about their project, they
know all the little details, they know the
minutia, they know all these decisions that
they’ve made.
But when they start talking to someone else
about their project, they don’t provide
the background that the person needs to understand.
They don’t contextualize the project within,
you know, that company's goals.
They don’t bring everybody in the room up
to speed and so they lose their audience.
Now when you’re thinking about where you
should start, when you want to start, you
know, at the beginning.
You don’t have to start, uh; it’s basically
two or three steps back from what you’re
thinking.
This doesn’t mean you need to start with,
first the earth cooled, then the dinosaurs
came.
But you do want to remember that context,
that for the person listening, their hearing
your idea for the first time and context lives
in the mind of the listener.
So st--, this is why you wanna start by stepping
back.
Assess what’s happening.
Um.
What, what are the audience’s expectations.
Assess their level of expertise.
And then start an, with an opening statement
that makes it easy for them to understand
your idea.
Ok, so we’ve started, we’ve covered start
by stepping back.
Now let’s move to the second technique,
write your pitch to be spoken.
What looks good on the page is very different
than what sounds good in the air.
And this is because of the way that listeners
can absorb information.
It’s the pace at which they can absorb information.
If you’re presenting something in writing
or you’re reading it, you can be very detailed.
You can break up big units of information
with bullets, and headers and footnotes.
Um, you can be very complex.
And readers can skim.
They can reread something that they are confused
about.
In a verbal pitch, the listener does not have
that same level of control.
So, you want to be very, um, careful about
the level of detail that you share.
And basically, uh, you, you, they can’t
rewind, they can’t, you know, figure out
those sections, uh, that are confusing to
them and they can’t control the pace of
the information that’s, uh, coming at them.
So this sounds really ridiculously basic,
but, one of the best ways that you can improve
your pitch is to shorten your sentences.
So, where you see long sentences, break them
up.
If you’re looking at, you know, the pitch
that you’ve prepared and you have a lot
of commas, try periods instead.
You want your s—sentences to be short, crisp
and direct.
It’s okay if the information looks choppy
and incomplete on the page, as long as it
sounds better in the air.
Ok, so we’ve covered, start by stepping
back and write your pitch to be spoken.
Now we’re gonna go onto the third technique,
which is, let the audience be the judge.
So now why am I even talking about this?
Of course, the audience is the judge.
This is totally self-evident.
But what I’m going to say may surprise you,
because I’m going to recommend that you
do, that you avoid doing something that most
people do.
Most people, at some point in their pitch,
tell the decision maker what to think or how
to feel.
Now, these are four things that I’m suggesting
that you should not say.
“You’re going to love this!”
“I have an amazing idea for you.”
“This project could be a game changer.”
“This idea will revolutionize the industry.”
So now what’s the harm?
These things show that you’re confident,
you’re thinking big.
You know, we know that decision makers like
people who are enthusiastic and who, ya know,
demonstrate that they are passionate about
their idea.
So, what’s the problem?
There are two main problems with this.
One problem is that for high level decision
makers, they are hearing lots of pitches,
and these phrases are so common that they
make you blend in, not stand out.
Every dog owner thinks their pet is adorable;
every parent, including me, thinks their child
is brilliant.
You are expected to be a fan of your own work.
But you don’t need to say it.
Now the second problem is more serious.
That is, that most decision makers, don’t
want to be told how to think or feel, and
they resent it if you do.
So for example, you’re saying, “You’re
gonna love this!”
And in their mind, their thinking, “Oh really?
You know exactly what’s going on in my head?”
or you say, you know, “I have an amazing
idea for you.”
And they think, “Seriously, you’ve concluded
that your own idea is amazing, I’m stunned.”
So what I suggest is that you completely eliminate
these sentences from your pitch.
And instead, look for third party validation.
So, the kinds of third party validator that
you’re looking for is someone who has credibility
with that decision maker.
And now this has a wide variety of applications.
For example, I have a two year old son named
Zach.
And Zach was not eating his broccoli before
I came on this trip.
And I was like, “Zach!
Broccoli is so delicious!”
And he’s like, “No!” and then I was
like, “But Zach, broccoli is gonna make
you healthy and strong!”
“NO!” and then I thought, I’m gonna
look for a third party validator, “Zach,
your friend Lucas loves broccoli.”
And then he tried it, and he liked it, and
he ate it.
So here’s the point, find credible experts
and if they support your ideas, share their
opinion, not yours.
Ok, so now we’re gonna move on to the fourth
technique, which is, sell yourself as well
as your idea.
Many people feel uncomfortable with the whole
idea of selling themselves.
They don’t want to brag, or have to act
fake, or, um, feel like they are being, you
know, they seem self-absorbed in any way and
that’s not what I’m suggesting.
First, as you know, decision makers are not
just investing in your idea, they are investing
in you and your ability to bring those ideas
to life.
One of the most common pitfalls that I see
is a lack of emphasis on the unique qualifications
of the person or the people behind the pitch.
Because decision makers know that there are
gonna be changes, obstacles, you know, issues
along the way.
And they wanna know that you are uniquely
qualified to be able to solve them.
This means, in the same way that you look
your pitch, and you find the most compelling
aspects of the project to talk about, you
want to present yourself in the same way.
And one of the best ways to do this is to
answer the hidden question.
In my experience, two, decisions makers ask
two main kinds of questions when their evaluating
an idea or evaluating a pitch.
The first kind of category is talking about
the project.
It’s things like, “What is this?”, “What
does it cost?”, ”Who is this for?”
, “What’s the time line?”, those kinds
of project related questions, are generally
easier to answer.
You can use research or data or statistics
and you can answer them directly.
But the second kind of question is more complicated
because it relates to you and your team.
And often, what the decision maker is really
asking is hidden behind another question.
Here’s an example.
They’ll ask you something like, “How did
you come up with this idea?”
Most people answer this question with, to
describe the eureka moment, something like,
“I was in the shower and suddenly it came
to me.”
But the decision maker is not asking you for
exactly at what time on what day did you have
this idea and what were you doing at the time.
How or why did you come up with this idea,
is really a way of asking you what unique
expertise, or experience, do you have that
allowed you to see this opportunity?
So, a question, a good answer, doesn’t involve
your shower.
But rather, it’s something more like, I’ve
been obsessed with this question for nine
years.
I did my grad school thesis on it and then
I invested my own money to build a model.
And once I built the model my key insight
came when I discovered that it was significantly
more efficient than I thought.
Dot, dot, dot.
You’ll get common questions like, “What
are your goals?” or, uh, “What made you
interested in this idea in the first place?”
Or, “What are some challenges that, you
know, are looking forward to?”
And in this case, when you hear questionslike
this, some general questions about you, pretend
that the decision maker has asked you, “Do
you have a story that exemplifies your expertise?”
or, “ How does your personal philosophy
relate to our companies goals?” or even
more directly, “Why should I trust you?”
Because that’s what the decision maker really
wants to know.
Now, this isn’t exact.
It isn’t like there’s a specific hidden
question behind every question that someone
asks, um, about you.
But if someone asks you one of those questions
about you or your team, it’s an opportunity
for you to sell yourself and your unique expertise,
and you should use it.
Now, here’s one way to create some great
answers for those kinds of questions.
Assess how you are different from the other
people who do a similar job that you do.
Think about some stories that you could share
that exemplify your expertise.
In other words, figure out why you are the
best person to bring your idea to life, and
then you can sell yourself as well as you
sell your idea.
Okay.
So now we’re going to move onto our fifth
and final technique.
Which is, embrace pitching early in the development
process.
So most people, well, first let me define
development.
My definition of development is the process
by which you take an initial idea and convert
it into concrete plans that can be funded
or implemented.
Now most people think of pitching as something
that you do at the end of the development
process, after you’ve already worked out
your idea and now you’re getting ready to
sell it.
And that’s a lot of why people don’t start
working on their pitch until, pretty much
right before their big meeting.
But the problem is that as soon as you start
talking about your pitch out loud, inevitably,
core problems to your main idea come out.
But at that point it’s too late for you
to do anything about it.
So, what I su--, and it’s really really
hard, at that point, to create a winning pitch,
once you know there’s some serious problems
with your idea.
So I suggest that you bring the pitching much
earlier up into the development of your idea.
So start by cr--, any time that you have an
idea, that you think is worth considerable
time and energy, I suggest that you take an
hour and write a short pitch.
Now a short pitch for your idea is simply
a one to two sentence encapsulation of that
idea.
And the goal of the short pitch is to assess
whether your idea is as good as you think
it is and, if it needs work, where you can
improve it.
So you take the short pitch and, I would test
it out on your friends or colleagues.
When you shared your short pitch with someone,
here’s what you’re looking for as far
as their feedback.
Where did they nod or smile?
Where did they frown?
What questions did they ask you?
What question did they ask you first?
So then you get that feedback from your short
pitch, you rework it, and you try it again.
You know that you are on the right track,
if your short pitch enables someone to act.
Here’s what that looks like, it’s like,
you, they hear the short pitch and your friend
says, “I’m in, how can I help?” or they
say, “ Oh, I know just the person that I
want to put you in touch with, let me call
so and so on your behalf.”
So this is a high bar for a short pitch that
you’re motivating someone to act.
But actually, it’s quite a reasonable one,
because eventually what your goal is, is that
you share the pitch in such a way with a decision
maker that they are motivated to act.
So.
Um, what I would say, as far as, um, a criteria
or how you’re figuring out whether your
short pitch is ready to go.
Like whether you should take your short pitch
and then continue developing the idea, is
once you have the sense that your friends
or colleagues want to support and help your
idea, that then you know that you’re headed
in the right direction.
So, today we’ve covered five techniques.
Start by stepping back.
Write your pitch to be spoken.
Let the audience be the judge.
Sell yourself as well as your idea.
And embrace pitching early in the development
process.
Now decision makers want you to succeed.
They often say no, almost always say no.
But they really want to say yes.
They want you to come in with a great idea.
They are really hoping, really hoping that
you have the answer, that you have this compelling
short pitch.
That you have a great, um, complete pitch
that motivates them to act.
They want to be thrilled by your ideas.
And they want to be thrilled by you.
So much time could be saved and so much pain
would be avoided if people with great ideas
learned how to pitch.
I have seen this work inside and outside of
Hollywood.
And my clients, who work at it, sell TV shows,
sell movies and secure financing for their
entrepreneurial ventures.
Now, I hope that these five techniques have
helped you to become better in a room.
Because when the best ideas win, we all benefit.
Thank you.
[clapping]
>> Stephanie Palmer: So now I would love to
hear any questions that you might have, specific
or in general.
>>Stephanie Palmer: Yes, in the front.
>> Male #1: [inaudible]
>> Stephanie Palmer: I’m gonna bring the
microphone over to you if that’s okay.
>> Male #1: Sure.
So in terms of like pitching in Hollywood
and around, you know, entertainment properties,
it seems like the elevator pitch is like this
idea of like, a very fixed short period of
time that you have to actually pitch to people.
Like, what would be your best tactics in terms
of like, getting your idea across in a really
short period of time, or is that like a misconception
and you actually have like an hour to really
sit down and lay out like in a very well-paced
form.
Like what’s your idea?
>> Stephanie Palmer: Ok, so the question was
about the elevator pitch.
And I am, um, one I think you only do have
a short time to make someone, you know, to
make a positive impression.
So I think that is still true and I think
that time period is getting shorter and shorter
and shorter as far as people’s attention
span and how much information is coming at
them.
But I am totally against the idea of an elevator
pitch, for a few reasons.
One, the term, elevator pitch, I don’t like
because I think it gives you the sense that
your actually supposed to pitch someone in
an elevator, which I totally don’t like.
I don’t think that you should ever pitch
someone, um, when you just have a moment of
access with them.
That access is not the time to actually share
a great idea where they could move forward
with it and say you’re a legitimate, um,
someone that I really want to do business
with.
The elevator, that’s never gonna be the
right, um, situation.
It also, the term, elevator pitch, makes you
think that you should just pitch to anyone,
who you see in an elevator.
Because I believe that, especially high level
buyers, are expecting a level of customization
and that an effective pitch is customized
to that specific person and to that specific
situation.
Exactly what their needs are.
Exactly who that person is, and an elevator
pitch that’s one size fits all, I tell everyone
my elevator pitch and everyone can inherently
tell that this is the same thing that you
say when someone asks you, you know, what
are you doing or what are you working on.
People know that it’s generic and it’s
one size fits all.
And no one wants to feel that.
They want to feel like they’re special and
you’ve customized this solution just for
that specific scenario.
Other questions?
Yeah.
>> Male #2: Uh, um.
>> Stephanie Palmer: I’m supposed to stay
over here but I’ll, I’ll respond, or you
can come over if you want to.
>> Male #2: First, I just want to thank you
for coming today.
You’re great.
Uh, and then secondly, as you probably know,
we worked with a ton of data.
right?
And uh, I’d love to hear your thoughts about
how you recommend incorporating data into
the pitch or making a more compelling pitch,
how it should support the pitch, or perhaps
not.
[Inaudible]
>> Stephanie Palmer: Ok, so the question—well
one, I’m very happy to be here, so thank
you.
Um, but also, uh, the question was about data,
and how to effectively include data in your
pitches.
Um, and for me, if it’s just a verbal pitch,
like if you’re just talking to someone over
the phone, data is really hard to convey,
effectively.
So I think you want to be very careful about
the amount of numbers and statistics and things
that you quote.
But a lot of times I know, and I know that
they do here use pitch decks.
And for me a philosophy of dealing with a
pitch deck is that, you are the pitch your
pitch deck is not the pitch.
So thinking of you being the lead and then
your pitch deck is just singing back up.
So, only using the pitch deck for ways where
there’s maybe a more visual way to convey
that information more effectively than talking.
But when you’re there in person, people,
they can get so much more information from
you, a human, who’s talking and make eye
contact and reacting to the situation and
making it customized so much more than anything
statistics, numbers, um, and all the other
data that you have.
So I think, um, thinking one, another question
that I would ask is, if there’s only one
piece of data that you want them to remember,
often decision makers don’t make the decision
right there in the room, that they have to
tell someone else.
So you’re not, you’re no longer there
in the pitch, but they have to re-pitch it
to someone else, so thinking, what is that
story?
Or what is that one amazing statistic that
they’ll remember, that they can use to re-pitch
why they need to be in business with Google
or why they need to do this specific thing.
>> Stephanie Palmer: Other questions?
Yeah, Mike?
>>Mike: So you talked in the beginning about
a lot of bad ideas making it through and being
successful, so I’d love to learn more about
pitching bad ideas, because I have a lot of
those.
[laughing]
>> Mike: Um, Sorry.
Um, what I’m really curious is like, do
you spend the time to put yourself in the
shoes, taking a step back is one approach,
but, thinking about your audience in a different
way.
Like, you know, you’re pitching to a movie
executive.
Should you try to put your hat on and pretend
that you’re them in a way?
Or how do you go about, like, figuring out
how to present it to the audience appropriately.
>> Stephanie Palmer: Ok, so how I figure out
the audience is actually, I do a lot of actually
putting myself in that person’s shoes.
That specific person, researching them.
What can I find out about them?
Because if I’m, I mean to use a Hollywood
example, if I’m pitching a romantic comedy,
my pitch might be different if I know that
person, the executive I’m going into, is
right in the midst of a divorce, versus if
that person is planning their wedding and
is really excited about it.
So I might customize the, the movie pitch
in some way.
Not, that I’m changing the, what actually
happens in the movie, but just how I’m positioning
it as context in the beginning of that pitch.
And I think that there’s a lot of ways that
you can do that, um, totally outside of Hollywood
of figuring out, “Ok, do I know that this
person, about what age do I guess they are?”
“Are they male or are they female?”
“Do I know that they’ve been at the company
a long time?”
If I’m putting myself in their shoes, for
that specific decision maker, because really
all that matters is the person who makes the
decision, can I guess from what I know about
them or their company, that they would benefit
from, you know, at what time of the year would
be great for them to be able to sign a huge
new client.
Or have I provide this solution that’s gonna
make them look like a hero to their supervisor
so they get promoted, they get a better job,
they get a raise, they’re thrilled, they’re
happy and they’re thrilled with you and
want to keep working with you because you
helped make them ,that specific person, look
good.
So I do think about all those, um, specific
scenarios.
Especially when there’s a lot at stake.
If it’s a really high stakes meeting, and
there’s a lot of money at stake that could
make a huge difference to your quarter, your
year, that’s where I’m really taking the
time.
Of course, you can’t do that with every
single phone call.
But when there’s a lot at stake, I do spend
a lot of time putting myself in that decision
makers shoes.
>>Stephanie Palmer: Other questions?
Yeah?
Great!
>> Male #3: Thank you, as well, for coming
by.
Um, I had a question about your final point,
about uh, pitch, starting the pitch, thinking
about the pitch early in the development.
And one thought I had, or question I have
is, um, is there, is there a problem with
people latching too hard on to, like, ideas
that are in the pitch and unable to sort of
de-anchor off of those ideas.
You know, have they started thinking as a
comedy, for example in the film, and they,
you know the idea isn’t gelling that way,
you know, and they drift from that, and you
know if we made this, you know something else,
then they realize, “ Oh!
That would work!”
But it’s hard for them to sort of break
free of those original pitch ideas.
Those original sorts of elements in there.
Is that an issue you’ve seen, and are there
ways to avoid that?
>> Stephanie Palmer: I think it is, you bring
up a really good point, it is absolutely an
issue that I see and I think that it’s another
reason for pitching earlier in the process.
Because it’s one thing if you’ve had an
idea and you’re working on it for three
weeks and then someone suggests a major change.
Or if you’ve been working on that for three
years and then someone suggests a change,
and you’re like, “No, that is not possible
that we’re doing it this specific way.”
So I think that brings a point of pitching
earlier.
Um, there are plenty of examples in Hollywood
where they think, studio executives and I
say this as a former studio executive, give
terrible notes.
And that writers basically hate, um, the studio
executives for telling them how to change
their project, and one of my clients was pitching
to a famous producer and he was pitching a
romantic comedy to star an actress like Kate
Hudson.
And he’s in the meeting with this big producer,
and the producer says, “I love the story,
keep everything the same, but change the lead
to a male chimpanzee.”
[Sigh]
[laughter]
>> Stephanie Palmer: And he was like, “Um”
But he was good, instead of saying, “No,
that’s the most ridiculous horrible idea
I’ve ever seen in my entire life.”
He was like, “You know, let me think about
it.
That’s something I hadn’t considered.”
And ultimately, they got to work together,
and now he has a two picture deal with that
producer.
So, even with the most ridiculous, you know,
ideas, you can still save the relationship.
>> Stephanie Palmer: Other questions?
>>Stephanie Palmer: Hello VC-ers, any questions?
Yes, you have a question.
>> Female #1: [Inaudible]
>> Stephanie Palmer: I think that that’s
true.
I think that, um, perhaps the, the question
was about whether, when you’re talking about
selling yourself, especially in your particular
situation, is when I talk about selling mys—selling
yourself, that perhaps it’s more important
to focus on how you sell Google as the solution.
And I think that for those ideas some will
work more for certain jobs and others, or
if you’re, your know, having an entrepreneurial,
you’re pitching your start up, that’s
perhaps where it’s more important.
But I think that if you are, um, forming a
relationship with a particular partner, and
you’re gonna be the contact, then I think
that they do want to know that there is a
human face to this ginormous, famous company.
And so the more that you demonstrate that
you are a real person, and also that you’re,
you know that you’re, there not, um, you
can play with the stereotype or their expectations
of Google in a nice way.
Where you can say, you know.
Obviously, we are the 800 pound gorilla in
this area, but I am a real person here and
here’s some ways that I’ve worked with
another partner, you know, another company
similar to yours who had this kind of concern.
Or share something about your personal background,
where you’re from, a story from your childhood,
from college of how you, you know, had a specific
way to solve this solution so they know that
there is a real human face.
Because I think that that’s, I can imagine
that being a concern for someone on the outside.
Other questions?
Anything else?
Alright.
Well, thank you so much.
And I’m happy if those of you have specific
questions, or a specific situation you wanna
do a little gaming, I would be happy to, you
know, talk to you in more specific.
Or if you want to e-mail me, I’m really
available.
So, thank you so much for having me, this
has been my pleasure.
[clapping]
>> Stephanie Palmer: Thank you.